digamos que tenemos un cubo y sabemos
que bueno vamos a pintar este cubo antes
que nada que ya estamos pintando la tapa
superior de nuestro cubo y aquí se
encuentran digamos una pared lateral del
cubo ok digamos que ahí tenemos este
cubo y digamos que su volumen lo
conocemos y es igual a 512 centímetros
cúbicos muy bien entonces mi pregunta
para ti es cuáles son o cuánto miden las
dimensiones de este cubo verdad entonces
cuando estamos pensando en las
dimensiones de un cubo por supuesto
estamos pensando en esta longitud que
podremos no se llamara lo el largo
podríamos pensar en esta otra longitud
que sería el digamos la profundidad y en
esta otra dimensión que es la altura muy
bien entonces como siempre te invito a
que hagas una pausa reflexiones esta
pregunta y trates de resolverlo por tu
propia cuenta
entonces digamos que cada una de estas
dimensiones como sabemos que es un cubo
cada uno tiene una dimensión o digamos
cada una de estas longitudes es igual a
x no sabemos cuánto mide cada uno de
estos lados verdad entonces pondremos
que es xy es el número que queremos
encontrar pero lo que sí sabemos es su
volumen son 512 centímetros cúbicos
entonces como calculamos el volumen de
un cubo pues esencialmente multiplicamos
cada una de sus de esas longitudes
verdad multiplicamos x por x por equis y
eso nos debe dar 512 verdad entonces si
nos damos cuenta esto es lo mismo que
escribir x al cubo debe ser 512 o bien
podemos decir que x es igual a la raíz
cúbica de 512 y entonces todo nuestro
problema se reduce encontrar la raíz
cúbica de 512 entonces una forma de
resolver este problema
a lo mejor no tenemos calculadora cierto
entonces hay que tratar de descomponer
este número 512 en primos como como una
facturación en números primos entonces
observemos que 512 es par entonces
podemos sacar una mitad verdad y sería
igual a 2 por 256 exactamente 2 por 256
256 es para así que lo podemos dividir
entre 2 puede ser 2 por 128 128 lo
podemos dividir entre 2 ok entonces
sería 2 por 64 el 64 se puede sacar una
mitad verdad sería 2 por 32 32 se puede
sacar mitad sería 2 por 16 el 16 se
puede sacar mitad sería 2 por 8 y el 8
se puede sacar mitad sería 2 por 4 y el
4 se puede sacar mitad y sería 2 por 2
muy bien
entonces como podemos ver 512 es igual a
2 por 2 por 2 por 2 por 2 por 2 por 2
por 2 por 2 9 veces estamos
multiplicando el 2 verdad entonces
tenemos 9 veces que se multiplica el 2
consigo mismo entonces podríamos tratar
de agrupar esto en digamos tenemos 9
números que tal si lo dividimos en tres
grupos por ejemplo este sería nuestro
primer grupo este sería nuestro segundo
grupo y este sería nuestro tercer grupo
verdad entonces 2 por 2 por 2 es 8 2 por
2 por 2 es 8 y 2 por 2 por 2 es 8
esencialmente lo que estamos diciendo
aquí es que 512 es igual a 8 al cubo y
entonces ya sabrás hacia dónde vamos
para responder este acertijo verdad
sabemos que x es la raíz cúbica de 512
verdad pero 512 es igual a 8 al cubo es
igual a 8 al cubo entonces si sacamos la
raíz cúbica de 8 al cubo podemos
simplemente concluir que x es igual a 8
y aquí debería escribir bien el 8x es
igual a 8 muy bien entonces lo que
sabemos es que cada una de estos de
estas longitudes mide 8 centímetros cada
uno de estos x es igual a 8 centímetros
así que esta fue una forma fácil de
llegar a esta conclusión